[Applause]
hello wow I I love this um I love this
New York apartment you moved into I oh
it's nice it's fabulous great digs I
know I love it I actually love being in
this building so much we're in the same
building now we're in the same building
now see you in the elevator I love I'm
listen I've had a milkshake burst in the
elevator too you're not the I I dropped
my matcha it went everywhere listen we
all done a Jackson poic in the building
I know it was my first day
man beautiful art it was also on the
ceiling I think Andy he caught it he was
trying to be nice it was everywhere okay
I've actually never had a drink drop
like that right well did it drop or did
it rock it to the sky I swear to God a
ghost was in the ele I I was holding it
and then I wasn't right like and I was
just standing there no one bumped me
like it just was like welcome to the
building like yeah yeah so I trash
things when I enter buildings it's fine
do have you ever had any mishaps here oh
definitely one time for a dry mishap I
um uh Rachel mat almost like I almost
Rachel mat was trying to open the door
for me once this glass door and then I
kind of leaned into it too much I could
have broken through the glass and killed
us both and it would have been a a gay
scandal in the
building specific Scandal specific
Scandal what's your favorite part of the
building because I had no idea like the
underground situation here it's it's
inredible it's amazing um I have a clear
favorite place in the building and I
took it upon myself to make a little
video for you where I I I I have not
seen this what is it it was I supposed
to set it up oh great ohing I literally
haven't seen it so yes hi Kelly welcome
to 30 Rock I'm going to show you my
favorite spot in the entire complex are
you ready for it it's the Dunkin Donuts
outside the subway every day I come to
work I order
myself a small iced coffee black and not
a dut but a banana so if anyone's
wondering who on Earth is buying the
bananas at Dunkin Donuts it's
me right here going to do that right now
and welcome to New York it's been
waiting for you judging you why I am
judging you who goes to Dunkin Donuts
for a damn banana oh I mean anyone in
something
glazed look the bananas are perfectly
ripe and look if you buy them in in bulk
if you buy
multiple put them at home and then once
they go soft make banana breath Sam's
clubbing it at D Don getting buying them
both I like it so this is exciting so
bad bunny is and SNL this week hosting
and musical guests right cuz been on but
never hosted right been on but never
hosted you know he was he played a
pirate in a sketch that I was in when he
was musical guest and he was amazing as
a pirate okay good which I think I can
extrapolate to me that he would be
amazing in any other capacity as well
I'm nail pirate you can nail it all yeah
yeah yeah it's it's the New York of
sketch ruls if you can make it there you
can make it any I heard too recently I
didn't get to see it but I've heard
everybody talking about it when Taylor
surprised and Kelsey was on there as
well was that I mean because that's
hilarious how the commentators it's not
hilarious how it is literally taking
over the NFL for people that like
watching sports now and you have to
watch like a a tutorial it's like you're
watching Housewives while you're
watching yeah they're just talking about
gossip things like so what about the
play yes yes but they're taking over
right yeah I thought it was funny that
y'all that's why I love about SNL y'all
touch on it like right then it's so
awesome that it's live and you're able
to like attack those things like at on
the weekends like right when it happens
right it was crazy like we no one for
fresh material oh yes yes thank you
Travis and Taylor for that um it was it
was it was so wild we didn't expect them
to come I Round the Corner they're at
the page desk and it's like I'm like oh
there's two of the tallest people I've
ever seen who are they right who is that
I was like I was like in the redwood
forest or something the mirror words yes
yes and then I was like oh my goodness
wow it's them okay they're here and it
was it was wild oh I love that so you
went to her aist tour right yes I went
to yeah I wasn't able to make it so I I
I imagine it was just first of all it's
such a clever idea to do that and have
everybody go because there's so much
Nostalgia happening for people that have
been fans for so long were you have you
been a fan for like a a minute I've been
a fan for a
long minute a long minute were you
afraid to say decade you and it's wait
it's been about a decade cuz I really I
ey latched on during red oh great album
yeah great album um no so it's it's it's
been a minute and um you know we've
we've we've all grown up with her yeah
and so it's it's it was so cool I
watched it from the floor and then with
Matt Matt my friend Matt Rogers and I
went and then we and then but then
seeing the Aras tour movie movie came
out the movie came out and it was every
I literally ate at a restaurant here
downstairs and we were leaving Caitlyn
who was serving us was like Hey and I
made these bracelets and she said
something and for the debut or something
and I was like I just went along with I
was like thank you that is so nice and
then I walked off we like what if they
talking about and they were they people
are so into it they were making people
just Rand are making like bracelets
passing them out to like she's got such
an incredible street team I know I was
like yeah amazing but yeah so the movie
came out and it like busted all these
like you know stats and record yeah yeah
which is not shocking it's Taylor at all
yeah but I love that you've been a fan
for so long I think we've all been a fan
of her music she's a great writer like
she so many great songs that was a look
at his new movie dick the musical it's
in theaters everywhere explain the movie
okay it is a very adult take on The
Parent Trap but it's a musical don't
bring your kids please an adult take on
The Parent Trap so these two businessmen
meet each other at work they find out
they're separated twins uh from birth
they plot to bring their parents back
together I'm sort of the narrator kind
of like a rocky horor picture situation
where I'm narrating as God the almight
you get to play God I get to play God
and then you had elenis Morris sit on
earlier I know she's played God she's
it's me elenis Morgan Freeman George
Burns we're the We're The Sex In The
City girls of
God the Mount Rushmore those could not
be more different people that's
incredible everyone could be God I like
it Osborne was right um so so if you're
yeah under 40 you don't get it um so
wait so did you always like musicals
growing up were you into musicals oh
yeah of course absolutely like it's it's
just do you remember your first one you
saw that you really love I think I think
my first one I saw was probably the
sound of music and undeniable oh yeah it
Up Sound of
Music um no I I was to say I think it
was like Sound of Music for me and also
funny girl I don't know which one I saw
first but those were the and I was like
this is incredible yes right it's
undeniably good and then like I just I
would take out like literally anything I
could find from the library like Wicked
and um I I can't think of anything else
that's the only music your your age your
age is shining through and wicked was
one of your Inspirations I was like wait
I was like that was so wait have you
ever played did you play a court jester
did I hear I was the Jester's understudy
in Once Upon a mattress
oh that wait so that's that's always
that's always hurt me because you have
cuz I had to do um we in in in high
school that we where there's a double
cast it's complicated and I learned all
this music and it wasn't underst
understand but it was like double cast
which really was understudy cuz I only
got one show I'm pretty sure and you
learned all that stuff you learned all
the stuff for one night for oh I was
like it was a lot yeah that literally
was like one performance and it was like
you that do you get is there a little
anger in that or resentment that you
learn all of that no are you lying I'm
lying okay cuz because I learned all
this stuff and it was so much I just
felt like do you pray that they get sick
no oh my goodness you're about to show
girls I wouldn't either I mean just one
like a little cold you know just a
little cold for one time the thr it's a
lot of material to learn it is okay was
it double cast because they just wanted
to make everybody happy like all the
kids happy at school we'll go with that
okay yeah yeah we'll go with that I mean
gosh I'm sure they're kicking themselves
now like oh we only gave Kelly Clarkson
One Night On stage it wasn't about me it
was Seven Brides to Seven Brothers so
that's a huge Double Cat yeah it taught
me a lot like about just working hard
just cuz you love it um quote unquote we
saw this photo though this is little bow
and and I just think it's adorable so
like wait like what birthday is this
you're so cute I think this is five I
think I'm five years cake do you
remember I was trying to figure it out
it looks like maybe like um Dollar Store
Power Ranger or something I don't know I
don't we couldn't tell like like the
producers of the show and I were like
doar we like what is that and like they
didn't know obviously and I was like I
don't think I know either but I'm I if
you look if you look at that photo I am
using my full cheek power look at that
where I know but I was convinced if I
didn't blow them all out in one breath
my wish was null and void oh I still
think that yeah me too I am 41 spitting
on cake I like it's like a fullon yeah I
don't want to I don't want to miss out
on my way
um I heard this as well which is kind of
odd to me your math teacher got you into
comedy what is the how does that how
does that workes how does that work um
very funny math teacher he was a very
funny math teacher he was he was cool he
moonlit as um an assistant director at a
comedy theater in Denver Colorado Okay
this tracks it tracks right and he and
like the the sort of crown jewel of
being in the drama club at our you know
big public high school was being on the
improv group we were only like eight
people was not a double cast situation
yeah and you were important yeah yeah
but but you know you couldn't audition
if you were a freshman you had to wait
till your sophomore year I didn't get in
in my sophomore year and then I got in
my junior it was this whole Saga and
then I um happened to be good at math um
with my glasses
and and then and then like I was I was a
good student and I was a good you know
little improv kid but you know I was 14
years old going downtown like bombing in
front of beer drinkers it was so strange
but it's that's kind of awesome though
it probably built up so much character
and like and and U armor you know what
I'm saying to be able to take the
hecklers able to take all that yeah I
mean not to bring in your personal
history like I can't imagine like being
on like a national slor stage is like in
my early exposure as a performer like
that for you that's like well imagine
you have no money no house you're living
in your car and you're like sure you're
like like yeah I think that helps though
I'm I'm being funny but like I do think
that helps like when people say are your
kids going to get in the industry I'm
like I don't really know man if they can
handle it like when you when you have
nothing you have nothing to lose so it's
like you know you go for anything and
say yes to everything so I think it's
maybe a little bravery maybe just like I
needed to pay my bills sure sure sure
that that that'll do it yeah did you
have those moments in this industry
because nobody really makes it like
right off the bat like everybody thinks
Idol is the first thing I ever did I
lived on a mattress in an apartment and
whatever but like it's but did you have
moments where you're like is this going
to hit oh yeah I mean I did you ever
have like you know ramen noodle weeks or
anything um I'm sorry did I live on it
yeah oh yeah by the way still love9
cents a thing yeah my daughter's
obsessed with it and I feel like a bad
parent giving it to her no no look how I
turned out well we can afford we're fine
we're fine we're fine no I do I feel
like a bad parent I'm like I should
probably cook you something else but she
loves it she loves this Put It crack an
egg in it put some scallions it's l oh
fancy yeah Meanwhile my son eats
anything the color of your shirt yeah
yep me too yeah he's I'm like cool bread
uh let's do another break everybody
Bowen movie dicks the musical is in
theaters Nationwide and the soundtrack
is also available
[Music]
[Applause]
now thank you guys yall have a great
night I'm going
home